action but sometimes in some
hamiltonians exact analytical
Expressions available for wave function
spectrum and then when we want we want
to modify MPS you know that it gives
exact analytical results when it's
available
the most famous
spill model is xXx Heisenberg
so let me remind
hamiltonian
um
M with a number of legislators and
capital to the lengths of the latest and
this is three polymetrices in one I just
said
three parameters is another latest side
it was entourages by Heisenberg himself
in 1929
and then eigenfunction was found by Hans
Builder
in 1932 long time ago
so of the other model which I'll be
talking about is very soon after it
wasn't rather introduced it was
generalized we can add magnetic field to
here I think notation is magnetic field
um
summation magnetic field summation all
Sigma z m
and then also very soon and is atrophic
formulation came up XX which I'll be
also talking about just need to adjust
notation for the beginning
um my annotation will be like this
summation the latest said
um Sigma X Sigma X poly matrices
um
M plus one plus Sigma y Sigma y
plus Delta Delta I will denote I'll just
change notation for this Delta soon
Sigma Z M Sigma Z M plus 1 minus one we
can also add magnitude filter along a
ziemann magnetic filter on Z Direction
the relation of this model is like this
when Delta equal to one this is xXx but
it's fair magnetic XXX meaning the
ground is a product status Fair magnetic
State when Delta equal to -1 then this
xxz Maps back to here with the plus sign
result magnetism one can actually for
the I will consider the case of even
Links of the letters m capital total
lengths of the latest is even number
then I can introduce unitary
transformation which is product of Sigma
Z in even letter says to M and M run
from in here so every other side and
this unitary transformation actually
will change this to minus signs into
plus and with Delta equal to 1 we map
back to here
um
further notations Delta this is
attribute parameter which plays very
important role
I will denote by cosine trigonometric
function of two ETA and this angle
either will appear in many formulas
later
um so eigenfunctions of the hamiltonian
the way which I mean Hansberry wrote it
this way so in order to write them down
I will need some notations like for
example sine function the Epsilon will
be send function which is equal to plus
one or minus one depending on if m is
greater than zero or M is smaller than
zero so this sine function will appear
will be made so eigenfunction of the
hamiltonian so I'm just trying to
diagonalize hamiltonian or I mean
diagonalize it
say and
energy
say n so this eigenfunction of the
hamiltonian
look like this
n will be different number I'm not
confusing the m is the length of the
letters n will be number of spin Downs
so in all the formals will be two in
different integer numbers
mm-hmm
oh
and and I guess so the eigenfaction
contracted like this I'm starting from
product State this is fair magnetic
state where all spins looking up in each
and every Ledger side then I flip the
spin down Sigma minus the spin lowering
competitor in some latest side let's
just say number M1 M2 M3 MN and then I'm
taking something new combination of
these states and sum up with respect to
the positions where the spins flipped
down
so Chi is a mini body wave function
which is the center piece of this better
than that
and then it looks like this
well cover
uh depends on a lot of stuff but let me
write it down
um
the cue is permutation so I will be pure
Music Moment of the particles well the
point of view this was like empty State
Fair magnetic State I flips one spin
down this is like a creation of the
speed wave speed wave sound similar to
the particle so sometimes I will miss
I mean I will be talking about stenones
or magnets sometimes they call them
particles
so Q is the permutation it will be
permission momentum of the particles so
summation will consist in factorial
terms
because I sum up with this n-factorial
terms so that many terms here
pirates of the permutation then plane
waves product of the plane waves
here I sum up with respect to all the
particles I mean overtone spins m is
coordinate like X position all the spin
down p is momentum well my mental should
later parameterize with something else
with some spectral parameter or rapidity
so that's the Lambda which will be
clarified soon and there is pairwise
interaction there is a double product
here I mean multiplied by product
um and here helps
um
um so that's a general structure of
Betances I will specify notations in a
moment but the genealogy of first of all
there is a lot of terms in factorial
terms so it's computation is not
efficient the way it's written
this piece is I'll say one body
reducible because without without double
product looks like three particles free
thermalines actually this is actual
interaction when two particles Collide
they go through one another they pick
extra phase this is actually actual
interaction and then also show that
model is actually interacting it's not
free so let me write this
parameterization I mean
um if I just use my Manta then
scheduling Matrix will be complicated
function of this moment it will depend
on the difference and the sum of
momentum so in order to simplify the
expression for the scattering phase I
will parameterize parameterize money
into some rapidity suspectful parameters
momentum will look complicated but the
scattering phase will depend on the
difference of this momentum that's the
reason of the interaction of extra
parameter so in the xxz case
and the exit case this Memento which
appears in here in the plane wave I will
parameterize well try the traditional
parameterization and the literature log
CH the cosine hyperbolic I mean I have
to write it down so I just show the
notation either Lambda is my spectral
parameter which will play a role will
parameterize moment and ether is related
to the coupling constant to another yeah
so this is my momentum in the case of
xxz and scattering phase which depends
then scaling phase depends the
difference of these lambdas and it look
like this sun hyperbolic
so it is
all right so this is
the total energy
um is equal to the sum of energies of
individual spin waves Epsilon of Lambda
Alpha
and then this individual energy of one
individual speed wave look like this
eat them to either and here I have my
differently
and also magnetic field
magnitude also often people impose
periodic boundary conditions on this
model this traditional in statistical
mechanics and those periodic boundary
conditions look like this
m is total length of the letters
p is this momentum parameterized by
Spectral parameter
and here
I have this product
of with respect to be them
and this is a pairwise scattering of
particle Alpha and other particles
I mean spin waves
oh this is pretty
diagonalization by Hans brother of this
xxz this is actually a complete set of
all states and well maybe this is for
xxz XXX looks very very similar on XXX
is just an exotropic this first one
which Heisler can reduce I just for XXX
I have to change parameterization P will
be I
log
I squared of -1
Lambda spectral parameter
this is under log and then
um
see the
will be with a log
um I plus Lambda I minus Lambda and
Epsilon energy of one individual spin
wave will be minus 2 square of the
spectral parameter plus quarter plus
magnetic field otherwise I just plug
this expression into here and I get
solution for either one so
anyway this was a solution by Hansberry
I mean solution the complete set of
eigenfunction of the hamiltonian and it
looks actually computational
non-efficient because I have so much
terms here and factorial terms if I put
in the computer it probably will crash
immediately
so
um our idea was like this first of all
when we look into this we first forget
about interaction look into the free
part this looks like Fourier transform
but Fourier transform we know that we
can do this we can calculate it
computationally efficient fast free
transform the command free transform
Center piece of shore algorithm because
I mean you managed to write it down as a
product fan factors and everything
becomes computational efficient and nice
so the idea maybe we can write this
thing this horrible sum as a product of
n factors
computers it's kind of yes and but we
need the tensor networks for this and
that I'm going to explain how to do this
So eventually we should rewrite these
wave functions and
so um
in the following form I will be
explaining notation we shall introduce
some creation operators spin lowering
Cooperators creation operator of the
eigen state of the hamiltonian and there
will be several of them I mean I have
several numbers here like minimum each
moment to correspond to Lambda so and by
the way this is not one equation this is
System of equation and here Alpha should
be one two three four to end
So eventually we'll be able to write
this eigenfunction the product of n
Factor each B creation variable depends
on its own Memento spectral parameter
and we apply these operators and
operates will be
um pure to this Fair magnetic state
which is product state
um these operators which I will
eventually
construct they're kind of nice because
they commit with one another
it will become clear out of the
construction
helps
and also eventually the tensor Network
which calculates this thing will look
like this
uh-huh well let me draw some picture
Maybe
so uh actually this is all I'm the ones
well the number ones and then this will
be representation of this B operator
then the next next view operator which
will have all them the twos inside
Lambda 2 connection
Lambda 2.
then also learn the two and so on each
line each line corresponds to one of the
B operators and the last one I'll have
like the dot the last one will be made
out of here on the end
only on the ends
uh
so this will be simple
Network and I'll be explaining what all
of this means eventually step by step so
this is like a block I mean everything
made out of this block and I will call
it elevator and let me specify so what I
will be trying to do right now I will
try to reproduce this wave function for
the XXX case so I'll be guessing this L
but I have some pretty good guidance how
I guess I'll explain as it goes on
so this first Elementary Block in this
Transit Network
VM right because I mean no no Triple M
actually have to be even even number but
this is number of the latest set the
total dimension of the Hilbert spaces
two raised to the power M but M due to
some technical reasons well remember I
multiplied everything along the even
letter side so I mean in order to be to
the religion to be bipartite it has to
be even legs so and so
this lead is different because I start M
with the products at all spin looking up
and then some of them I flip down that's
m capital which is smaller than M cable
those are two different integer numbers
and kind of should not be confused
this wave functions see the wave
function is like scattering phase of n
particles and skin waves and and magnets
and then this tensor Network represent
this wave function which was eaten by
Hans bet in 1932 last millennium so
that's a different representation
which I mean supposed to be to be
computationally efficient because I'm
following ideas of Peter sure like
instead of portable sum and factorial
terms I'm on the product of n Computing
terms so I expect this will be better
computational more efficient
anyway so I'm trying to build this kind
of network so first of all this square
like Elementary see this is like really
simple things it will be linear function
spectral parameter for the XXX okay so
I'm just guessing this and then telling
you the result of the guess
so this Elementary block out of which
the hole tensor Network built um of
course this is uh physical indices
Quantum indices and this is auxiliary
and silly indices like standard normal
um argility that we will use the word
auxiliary I have to combine two
languages of tensor Network and
algebraic with answer so sometimes I
will you know use double terminology
and this elaborator that's a notation
m l so M this Liberator corresponds to
one physical site this is set number one
of the latest of the physical I mean in
here I have this ordered spins right
this I have in mind like other letters
set number one some number three and so
on so in the beginning they were ordered
so this each of this vertical correspond
to one letter set another third and this
is like physical actual appearance so
this is a literature physical indices
inside number n and dependence spectral
parameters should depend on spectral
parameter I know that my wave function
should what certainly depend on the
momentum
so look like this Lambda linear function
spectral parameter and then I write
minus
equivalent of minus one and here
so those Sigma Quantum spins they act
non-trivial in the quantum Direction and
this is auxiliary space so this is
horizontal this is the operator
and then I'm going to build the whole
tensor Network for the wave function out
of this so maybe I just also write a
liberator for the so this is xXx case
XXX isotropic is like more primordial
and xxz case
um I'll write it differently for X exit
case elevator the elementary block
um I would write this as explicit Matrix
in auxiliary space and explicit Matrix
and oxidative space look like this
cosine hyperbolic function Lambda
spectral parameter
foreign
Quantum spin
and here
and here I'll have
another cosine hyperbolic spectral
parameter another quantum spin
well in principle I can also write this
as explicit matrices two by two then it
will look similar so just as I said
different languages right
so this elevator they satisfy some
remarkable equation which is called the
Young Baxter equation so let me write it
down and then explain mathematical and
physical meaning of this young Baxter
young box is the equation at the very
center of this solvability
solo models
foreign
so what this means
um here I have the same let's say so
Quantum operators this one are the same
here but one two means that I have two
different copies of auxiliary spaces
like here and here so this is that the
product of two auxiliary space like
graph is speaking four-dimensional space
so these are matrix it's it's kind of
intensive product of 2c2 both of them
auxiliary and then I have explicit
expression for this R I'll write them in
somewhat different form so both XXX and
x y z both XXX and xxz will fit in the
same notations
function the physical meaning can be
compared to three models in free model I
can say that Dynamics is one body is
useful if you just diagonize hamiltonian
in one body sector I'll figure out well
all quantum numbers then nothing else
happens in many body sectors okay just
multiply one body wave function
anti-symmetrize them and that's it the
answer is not free because two particles
when they Collide there's a cadric
matrix which depend on my answer but the
whole dynamic of buildings that is
totally reducible so to put the
reducibility is the central property of
this build and the solvable model our
Matrix which enter into here
so it acts intends the product of two
two-dimensional spaces so I can write
this as my Flemish Matrix
oh just some specific notation for the
Matrix elements
this is F this is G
and then this is f again
this one
and this f and g are just functions
normal functions they're different than
the XXX and x x z case XXX case
one number square root of minus one mu
minus Lambda and Jesus this is G where
Lambda is I minus lamb so this was XXX
case in the XX Z case which is Q
deformation this is I have to use this
sign hyperbolic
function
foreign
all right so by now by now we have all
these notations so this Elementary block
which I'm trying to sell you for the
tensor network is elevatory satisfy this
equation this is Young Baxter equation
this is mathematical representation of
the idea of topological disability I can
rewrite this sometimes people write this
like this one two three equal to
one
two three and this exactly
mathematically means that many body
scattering Matrix is tensor product is
product of two body scattering
okay anyway nice what I do next so I'm
telling you that for elementary block I
have chosen this elevator which has this
nice commutation relation but this
relation is really beautiful because
it's withstand something which called
command application so What's this
called multiplication
uh-huh so I'm still trying to explain
really notations in my tensor Network
foreign
Matrix is this piece so I just take
several hello periods multiply them into
auxiliary space and this is important
evidently for understanding of my tensor
Network so this one line This Lambda
Quantum sticking ground
same Lambda
so I must apply a little bit it's an
auxiliary spacebar Quantum indices this
is a standard product of quantum space
so there is some specific notation
sometimes people do notice by see this
is a traditional notation of better
answers and sooner or later I will need
to write this as explicit Matrix in the
auxiliary space in the auxiliary space
this is actually Matrix two by two so I
can write like a
b c d and a b c g are quantum operators
in all of the spaces so sooner or later
so what's good about this what's good
about this relation then it will stand
this common multiplication in other
words T is satisfy the same commutation
relation like L let me write them down
that's a central property Sometimes some
people call it from local to Global
anyway so my tea I can write another
mathematical formula so T equivalent to
this I can write l l in the first letter
said Lambda multiplied by this second
letter said and so on and then last
let's say and then these things satisfy
the same relational operator the same
arm Matrix exactly the same still four
by four
then here I have children the
female
I can put this indices so this is first
auxiliary space second first auxiliary
space second and this is one two one two
aromatics is exactly the same see this
is like remarkable theorem that
everything works because of this
multiplication so starting from here if
this is valid for each and every
elevator in here then I can prove that I
skip the proof because you know given
ideas all right so this is important
there is several consequences out of
this immediate consequences first of all
in principle I can divide by this I mean
multiple R inverse from the right hand
side and then if I do that
um are
children the
female are inverse female
cylinder I can take Trace of this in the
four dimensional space in the whole time
the product of two little spaces then
this thing will cancel right and I'll
guess and I'll get something in order to
write it down any sub notation so of
Lambda is Trace
space so this means this is a of Lambda
plus Z of Lambda and if I take place for
this in four dimensional space then the
product of two auxiliary species are we
immediately obtained that these things
come with one another
Lambda is a scalar in auxiliary space
but this is quantum operator actually it
will be closely related to hamiltonian
and then this Tau of Lambda commutes
itself at different values of spectral
parameter I mean if I take Trace this
will cancel but here I have learned the
MU here I have new Lambda right
commutation
there is also some extra
um because
um
these are metrics has some special
properties some special value would
Lambda minus mu is equal to I it turned
into the slope gate into permutation and
this is really helpful in order to write
the local hamiltonian I can actually
well let me write it down first and then
comment later so XXX we're talking about
XXX the hamiltonian I wrote down
remember the highest number 29
um so if I take logarithmic derivative
of these trace of Monument a special
value of spectral parameters that can
represent the original hamiltonian XXX
the one which is 1929 of high school so
this is nice because I can take a
logarithmic activity here then you know
I'll get that my hamiltonian I mean
Heisenberg hamiltonian XXX commute with
children in the valley of London this is
infinitely many conservation laws uh so
someone similar to breakfast if you want
I can write some of them and it doesn't
look like yours but I mean if there will
be some I mean I can write some of them
if it's interest anybody
do you want me to write them okay but
they don't look like yours
okay so consideration laws by now I
understand
they're not local they look like
hamiltonians so Amazon and describing
directions
conservation law describes three uh
interaction of three U.S neighbors and
then four or five and so on each of them
are local we call them local because
it's a sum of the local density one
multiple sum of local dentists so it's
not local like Sigma you have to sum up
some local Expressions
local because it's a map of local
expression
what is like super nice you know I hope
you say that I was trying to provoke you
so Epsilon ABCD this is anti-symmetry
tensor right
so the first non-trivial conservation
law which comes so which can be done so
look like this summation
and here I have three nearest neighbors
like Sigma
Sigma Sigma a b c m n plus one M plus
two and then let me resist
Epsilon a b c so I think three
problematicism anti-smetricization like
a volume sum up so this one can prove it
comes with a humidity you want me to
write all of them fastly all of them the
rest okay
um in order to do that we need this
boost operator well the rest of them we
need to obtain recursive I mean like I
know hamiltonian then I know the next
one and I I if I know any of them how I
get the next one and it's done by means
of boost operator
um yeah I hope you remember this
um so boost operator looks like this
um
some similarity to hamiltonian info XXX
case Sigma Sigma M M plus 1 multiplied
by m
and then the consideration laws
constructed like this the conservation
law number L plus one is equal to
commutator or consideration number L
with the Boost operator so for example
this one is a commutator of the
hamiltonian of the post
this one I can calculate you know blah
blah blah but if I calculate it
combinator of this with the Boost I get
the next one and the next one and
actually all of them as you see complete
set they they have more and more time
yeah yeah yeah yeah so this is three
next well four will have four
interaction and so on and so on till the
full length of the laces okay anyway
um we just trying to
um write the we function factorize the
wave function better three function
um our Matrix I hope you remember but by
now we actually want to write this
commutation relations more explicitly
remember I told you that I can
derive this commutation relation right
here so this is very explicit Matrix 4x4
and the t is you know like one line of
this tensor Network which I wrote as
explicit Matrix two by two in the
auxiliary space so now I want to
understand better the commutation
relation of this Matrix elements of this
t a b c d between themselves so let
them some of this commutation relations
I have to read something
um
okay first of all be compute with itself
I mean out of here I mean I think this
is a quality of two matrices four by
four it's my point of view so I can just
multiply row by the column I get 16
scholar equalities so let me write a
table some of them are useful some less
useful so let me write three of them the
ones which I will use uh the one number
one which everybody likes is B operator
which later will be creation of a spin
wave creation operator cam it was itself
a different release of momentum
so the other one looks like this
aoperator it has conservation lowers and
B is creation right
uh-huh
and for the similar
I mean
a plus G the trace of the laundry Max
depends depends I mean it can use with
hamiltonian so I I will try to
diagonalize all of them simultaneously I
will try to find eigenfunctions of T of
Lambda which is a and this is a of
Lambda plus geoflameda I can diagonize
all of them simultaneously they commute
and I expect that eigenvectors will not
depend on Lambda I mean in the end of
the day they come use so eigenvectors
should depend on something but not on
this Lambda
and that will come out eventually so and
okay so Z operator
I mean a plus d has a hamiltonian so
that's the thing which I want to
diagonalize
here I have f
f is some scatter function element entry
of aromatics
okay so this is really really useful
computation relations but the good
um but I need something else I need
highest weight Vector remember I'm
applying my NPR to some Vector to this
Fair magnetic state which is product
state so I need to know how the entries
of this T and individual operators apply
to this ferromagnetic State I mean in
the end here I have this Fair magnetic
state right I apply all of this so
um just pure computational relation is
not good enough I need to know a
liberator erase of course
so I want to apply this operator to the
state with spin up in his latest side
um and this elaborator looks like this
was some cosine here I have like Sigma Z
another question Sigma Z something here
and here I have Sigma plus M multiplied
by something so I apply this to
pheromagnostic State Sigma plus X and
confirmative this will vanish right and
this Vector is eigenvector for Sigma Z
right
so it will turn triangular elevator
after applying a turn triangle so what
will happen with this elevator let me
let me write it down so after I apply
this to this pinup State I get the
following cosine Lambda minus I ETA I
had Sigma Z here but they turn into one
after application here zero here I have
some non-trivial operator
m
sent to either and here I have cosine
Lambda plus I either Sigma zero so
disappeared because I applied this okay
nice triangular Matrix but I mean in
order to get my monitor my Matrix I had
it somewhere so my money so it's a
product of elaborator that L1 L1 Lambda
L2 Lambda into auxiliary space and L
um Lam Lambda well triangular matrices
is
by two triangular medicine you get also
triangular matrix it's a group right so
that's nice so this means that in
principle I can calculate the
application of my abc0 operators to the
ferromagnetic State well at least C is
equal to zero because it's lower
triangular element
so what comes out by now I can take the
whole C operator which is product of an
operator which is this whole thing which
is kind of non-trivial and then apply
this to fully ferromagnetic State this
product stage in each and every every
let's just set it will turn remember
realizing this is the explicit Matrix
into auxiliary space it will become
triangular some complex valid function
uh this is I'm just looking oh B I'm
sure it's B
and uh
so minion quotes the zero Creator well
tensor Network
well maybe maybe you remember this okay
so no I will I'm sure that I will have
to draw it again but as soon in space
so what we got out of here the seal
really radiation operator kills this
sphere magnetic product stage so this is
highest rate vector and this eigen
functions I can calculate for example
XXX a XXX
of Lambda will be equal to Lambda minus
I divided by 2 raising the power total
length of the letters g will be a
complex conjugated
raising the power and then for x6z I
also have some expressions
um so by now
prepared to prove that I can stress this
eigenfunction of the hamiltonian so with
all of this I want to show or to prove
that this
construction starts for fair magnetic
state which is product State then I
apply apply my B operators B of Lambda n
B of Lambda n minus one blah blah blah
also let me see some notation say n what
I can do right now I can sum up my two
operators a plus Z
I mean they commute with hamiltonian and
they contain all the conservation laws
and if I diagonalize them then I will
know eigenvectors of the humanitarian I
want to apply to here well I'm equipped
because I want to to move a through the
products of BBB I can use this
commutation relation this is kind of
nice term a go through give some Factor
second term creates some trouble and
some terms which I don't really want
here is similar the first terminal this
is some kind of a factor when B goes
through D just some Factor this is
trouble maker we have to cancel
contribution of this
if I just apply this and then eventually
if I use this A and D will hit this Fair
magnetic stage and will turn into one of
those functions a and z
so in principle if I calculate this
carefully kill the contribution of
advanced term I'll get the eigenfunction
so the result of this calculation look
like this Theta is depends on everything
so it's a number it's complex valid
function not an operator depends on
Lambda and on moon is not an operator
that's a number and the same size n so I
managed to construct eigenfunction but
um this lambdas has to satisfy some
equation to kill the contribution of
unwanted terms and this extra equation
in the abstract form they look like
Lambda G
this is eigen values of this diagonal
operators
and K from 1 and F ratio to F's
Lambda G and the K yeah the K and the g
equal to one so this is condition of
cancellation of these unwanted terms
which appear from here I can write this
more explicitly in the end of the day
you know F explicitlyn or all of this
ABCD so I've read for XXX then this
equation will look like this uh Lambda
I divided by 2 this is index G Lambda G
minus I divided by 2 raising the power
total length of Oasis is equal to the
product
okay from one and here I have Lambda G
Lambda k i square root of minus one
um this is good equations actually
because Hans better wrote them this is
periodic boundary conditions remember
when I wrote originally in you know in
1932 hence built impulse periodic
boundary range that's exactly periodic
boundary conditions
so it's kind of nice I can compare this
wave function BBB with this expression
which I had summation with Vector Q to
permutation all eigen values I mean I
also can extract energy from here
I can you know new dependence doesn't go
into here it depends only into here so
if I take logarithmic derivative of this
thing I will get energies and energies
also will fit into the expression which
runs better obtained so I have feeling
that this thing BBB is actually
proportional to the eigenfunction which
I wrote in the very beginning summation
with respect to permutation well to be
on the safe side I can take I can take I
have explicit expression for Aleppo so I
can take it like multiply all of them
and calculate this BBV and it will feel
this is exactly the wave function which
hands better Road this links the
calculations I am skipping but there is
a straightforward Brute Force proof that
this BBV reproduce exactly the wave
function which I wrote in the beginning
the wave function which originally was
written in the sum of N factorial terms
now the product of n factors in pure and
they commit with one another and we have
a tensor Network for this
before
um and then this kind of related this
spin chains they're not pure
mathematical objects by now their
experiments done in Optical lattices
where people try to build this
um screen chains people shine lasers to
one another get a stinging connector
magnetic wave pool put cold neutral
atoms which were the dipole more moment
because of the interaction with the wave
and then the upper moment interact back
and the atoms because of the interaction
with the wave got some dipole moment
which interact back with this way so
cold atoms stay in the Maxima of this
tension collector magnetic wave called
Optical laces and this can be
one-dimensional two-dimensional
three-dimensional and actually people
can build this XXX and XZ in the lab
but and the people who do this in Europe
York Smith Meyer and even in Steinberg
Dominic Schnabel we have our own
experimentalists in Stony Brook who's
also doing this it's called simulation
part of the part of the title of the
workshop
simulation
um of course they can build but it's
finer places and also no periodic
boundary conditions either so we
actually need to modify all of this to
the open boundary conditions not the
periodic boundary condition before we do
that
before we modify tensor networks to open
boundary conditions we need some extra
piece of algebra from this in order to
move to open boundary condition so the
extra piece of algebra out of this ABCD
operators there's something which is
called Quantum determinant and unsupport
and we'll need that
so
um if I have normal Matrix just with
complex entries Matrix
if I want to invert it
I mean this is Matrix to buy two then
this clever formula I can write in the
compact way which is Sigma y then here
Matrix transposed uh-huh this is a
matrix transpose Sigma y divided by the
detergent this is usual grammar formula
which is known for many years it turns
out that something like this can be
applied to cheese I want to invert my
Monograms it's anti-schoolant vibrator
so it's not as easy but something like
this works and inversity called answer
so
um the main idea out of this I mean
aromatics dependence Vector parameters
if the difference of these two spectral
parameters in the XXX cases I for the
XXX guys then aromatics become highly
degenerated
Matrix look like this with this one one
minus one minus one versus zero this is
one dimensional projector so to
determine this is really the general so
computational release becomes very very
special with the difference between
Lambda and M is equal to Y then
everything becomes very very special so
this helps helps us to Define command to
determinant Quantum determinants of the
several results for some operator which
commute with a b c d and which each and
every Quantum entitle which I saw in
this construction so this Quantum
determinant has some formula
come on from the terminals to learn the
my a operator for the XXX case
minus
B
let's see
so what's so remarkable this thing
commandment commute with all the
operators which I so I mean if I take
any Matrix elements of T adcg it will be
zero the center of the output okay this
is nice and then I can use this in order
to invert this uh using this formula
so T inverse
look like this the same Sigma y
Sigma y the T here I have to transpose
but I have to shift the spectral
parameter this is transposition
Lambda plus I and then I divide by
Micron to determinants and Quantum of
Lambda plus I divided by two it's called
answer for C important for I mean young
boxer algebra and also in order to
rewrite this tensor Network for open
boundary congestions
so let me erase all of this now we
change boundary condition from periodic
to open boundary condition so I'll
change even notations a little bit
because there's different communities of
people who do open boundary condition
they use well let me write it down it's
called reflection reflection algebra the
algebra we share about to explain called
reflection algorithms with some people
who invented this and then already
listening is momentarily
okay
so there's two people who invented how
who reformulated
um
yeah anyway I'll be using the algebra
which was designed by two people first
yeah so I got confused by one thing so
we are going to do open mother yeah
that's also that goes down sometimes
it's history yes that's yes and first
approximation but then I can give
details there is a
French book Michelle golden from soccer
he wrote this book it's in French and in
Russian but with coordinate but the
first form of a writing function which I
refer to Hans vert is called coordinate
transits so Michelle Gordon wrote um the
coordinate but under Swift and four open
boundary conditions in that book okay
but then this is not good for us because
it's even more terms it's like in
air multiplied by two raising the power
n so if he solve it but computational
efficiency went down is even more
complex so we don't want that we want uh
the bracketanzas which is tensor Network
and tensor network was reformulated by
two other people and then I'm about
those are foreign people with foreign
Russian names so I have to transliterate
the names on the Blackboard
Nick
he's in North Carolina right now
so they invented something which they
call a reflection algebra basically it
is
yeah
so I wanted to understand the connection
with Maddox product States and whether
there will be new tensor Network you
want me to draw the sensor Network so
the tensor Network for open boundary
condition will be different I will have
like instead of a line I will have a
loop
but before drawing this I was going to
feed you with some more algebra
so
um yeah
use different mutations first of all
young Works equations still important
for open boundary condition the
aromatics for XD cases it's exactly the
same but they use U instead of Lambda so
spectral parameter will will be you and
there's some couple of other changes
notation so spectral parameters was
Lambda
um it's still 4x4 automatics and still
the end is
um so this is a
b c
hey impulse are still a trigonometry
trigonometric hyperbolic functions just
a little bit of change of notation
cell hyperbolic U plus ETA those are
elements of my this was my f and g
and B is the sun hyperbolic of U and C
is
so these automatics still satisfy the
unbox the equation your unbox the
equation like roughly speaking R cube is
equal to R Cube but I need like three
spaces but I wrote this in some precise
way so let's leave it let's leave it
rough for now
um but in order to formulate this open
boundary condition well the fictions
this is my latest
and then there's some work
with spin wave that reflects from the
wall and go back then it reflects from
this wall uh there is um
of the wave from the wall it has it's a
new element it was not present before
and it's denoted by K in our case it
will be Matrix two by two depends on the
spectral parameter and there's some
um equations the reflection algebra
which they have to satisfy and this is
like addition to Young Buck so I just
want to write it down and then also
write the picture
so this young Buck's equation reflection
algebra generalization again
the difference between spectral parents
which we saw before is the Reflection
from the left wall
then
this well anyway U1 plus U2 so this was
the difference this is a sum and here
Reflection from the other wall and this
is like one uh auxiliary space another
auxiliary space due to and this is
supposed to be equal to K minus
you two are one two
okay one
minus of U1 or one two let's call it a
reflection algebra and then one of our
courses managed to write 30 picture for
this young box equations could be cubic
relation remember I wrote it like this
so just
um the meaning of this that one line
moved through the intersection of twice
I just lift this three through this
section that was that was young Baxter
in here the picture for this new
equation is like this so K is the third
square with the third error so the
picture is like this for this I'm trying
to draw this equation
foreign
minus you run this U2 minus U2 and this
is YouTube minus U2 I minus YouTube in
here
uh
U1 minus U1 so the meaning of this so
this is my K Matrix
the section is automatics aromatics
aromatics
basically means some equation which
inter I mean entangle
um Reflection from the wall Matrix
describing reflection of the wave from
the wall with the static Matrix between
themselves so this is additional extra
piece of equation which are necessary
for model with open boundary condition
to be solvable
kids are generating algebra oh no no no
no okay I mean at first I sold the
unboxing equation and fixed equation for
something which was known before xxxvz
then I write this equation try to find
some solution and some solution which
has physical meaning can have a
corresponds to a nice hamiltonian and
the case which I will have in mind in my
example what are the generators of the
algebra for X success everything based
on su2 algebra originally everything was
based on a super algebra there are more
hidden symmetries of this but probably
for the infinite laser set the algebra
get elevated to Infinity dimensional
representation of Yankton but I'm not
using this in here
people call this young box they're out
of brows but over this ABCD the one
which I wrote traditionally in the
literature they call it young boxers
so okay our metrics I would have in mind
okay the simplest K which is used I mean
in the papers by scalarian
um and she didn't it's key dependence
simplistic this is diagonal matrix two
by two so same hyperbolic here I have a
spectral parameter plus some another
beam and humans
sensing you
you minus PSI so what I'm saying that
this K solved this equation this is a
solution explaining the genetic solver
so just not ad hocsync I have to check
it on somebody else over the detectors
so from now on I can try to reproduce
all these nice algebraic obstructures
which I have with periodic boundary
condition I try to you know construct
them here and then what comes out
remember I have this confusing family
like infinite many conservation laws and
I have a generation function of
conservations which was a A plus d right
so instead of a plus Z in open boundary
condition I have something else which is
Trace in the auxiliary space of this
okay plus I have to work the fraction
from the this is K plus Reflection from
this one and K minus inflection from
this wallet so I have K plus another
plus I have some local magnetic field in
the first place is set plus local
magnetic field in the last place is set
that's initial extra thing and the
tensor Network look like this right now
so I have to do this just I drew tender
Network and then this will be itch
because there was questions about it
so the internet Network look like this
I remember I have this my elevator and
one spectral parameter the same spectral
parameter this is auxiliary space this
is some specific Vector then I continue
like this and this is as many as the
length of the letters if you want
multiplication in multiplication in the
auxiliary space then this K Matrix and
then I go back backwards V1 in the same
letter set in the same Quantum space and
then this is V1 in the same like here
and then go back to here still V1 and
then another Matrix element I have to
repeat this for each and every V's so
it's kind of this tensor network is kind
of doubled comparing to pu as it was K
instances in the middle
so so since I've ran in a couple of time
we have the standard Network for open
boundary condition also we can calculate
expectations we can calculate
correlation functions and the
correlation functions for open boundary
conditions defining places there's no
other way to calculate except of our
tensor Network so we just calculate them
numerically using some numerical ideas
which were published by Ignacio and
Frank and Mork in the previous
publication and then this is helpful for
these simulations which is done in
Optical leases
and so we try to relate standard network
with simulation that's a subject of this
workshop and the end of my lecture okay
from this reflection algebra you also
get the new set of equations for the
spectral parameters yes yes
um I mean thank you for asking this
question
just present all the transverses which
you didn't
so x minus MP this was the left hand
side for periodic boundaries so I put 2
MP because go to the left go to the
right then hey I mean k11 of you and in
the right hand side I have this product
of asthma this is remember minus I see
that was Lambda J minus Lambda K but
here I also L will subtract Cedar of
Lambda J multiplication with respects
okay plus Lambda K so double links here
Reflection from the wall and here this
is old fracture like in periodic
boundary conditions but and here this is
like the wave go backwards so instead of
the difference you get the sum
and this equation is in the godance
Clarence always but they do change
okay the normal question that uh